Sure
you often give advice to young adults to help them avoid some of the pitfalls of
life.
Any advice for those of us who are 40 plus who have already faltered?
Look first I'm,
this is Graham.
Everybody who 40 pluses as already fault her,
but,
but I'm presuming that you mean faltered in a manner that it appears to you to
be above out above the average.
Right.
Well,
okay.
What I would really recommend is I think that you should,
if you haven't already,
you should go do the future authoring program and maybe the past authoring
program too,
because you should figure out exactly how you faltered.
Like what exactly did you do wrong by your own buy your own analysis,
right?
I'm not saying,
well what social rules did you break?
Although that's not a bad initial guideline.
It's like,
so in the self authoring suite,
there's a past authoring module and it asks you to break your life I to 70 parks
and then to consider the emotionally significant or practically significant
events within each epoch in the detail out there,
emotional nature and their consequences and so on.
And one of the things you might want to figure out is,
well,
when you say that you faltered,
like what do you mean exactly?
And I mean exactly go over your life with a fine tooth comb.
This is what Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn did by the way,
in the Gulag before he wrote the Gulag archipelago,
he went over his life and said,
okay,
well like where did I go wrong?
What did I squander?
What mistakes did I make and what did I do right so that you can orient yourself
now and then you want to think,
and this is why we built the future authoring program.
Well look,
you got 40 years left man.
So what do you want them to be like?
So what do you want to aim at?
You know at least how are you going to minimize the misery if,
if,
if nothing else.
And so you need a plan and then what you need to do is to figure out how to work
day to day so that you incrementally approach that plan.
So I have another chapter in this new book called compare yourself to who you
were yesterday.
Rather than to who someone else's today.
That's really a useful psychological stance for someone who's 30 and over in
particular to a 20 year olds can still kind of compare themselves to other 20
year olds because all 20 year olds in some way are the same,
but 40 year olds are really different from each other and so,
or 30 year olds for that matter.
So you might think,
okay,
well
ear,
here's a,
here's a meditative strategy for for ceasing to falter.
You could wake up in the morning or you could do this at night before you go to
bed and you could think,
okay,
look,
I want to structure my day tomorrow so that when I,
when I'm done with the day,
my life is in slightly better order than it was when I woke up this morning.
Just slightly better because incremental progress is massively,
massively effective because it bears a exponential fruit.
I just like a bank account,
um,
compounds,
incremental progress compounds with time.
So you can get up in the morning and you could think,
okay,
there's some things in my life that I could put in order today.
They're usually things you don't want to do.
As I mentioned earlier,
what could I do today that would help put my life in order that I wouldn't do?
And you have to ask yourself.
You can't tell yourself.
You have to ask yourself what would you do?
And then maybe you have to say,
well,
or maybe you have to say under what conditions would I be willing to do
something to put my life in further ordered today?
What little reward would I need to give myself?
And these have to be questions you can't like take out the whip and boss
yourself wrong because you'll find that you're a terrible master and a worst
slave.
And so you can get a long ways if you look low enough.
One of the things Carl Jung said,
which I really liked was that modern people don't see God because they don't
look low enough.
They don't have the humility.
Now you said that you have already faulted.
So it sounds like you've got to humility already intact.
So I would say think about what you want.
Think about what you know around you isn't set right.
Cause you'll know it.
Make a list of things that are around you that aren't right.
And then start thinking about small things you can do,
like trivial things that even a fool like yourself could manage that would
orient you in the right direction and help straighten out your life and try that
for a year before you decide that you're a failure.
You know?
Because you'll find that if you put that into practice for a year,
that things will be a lot better.
And like I said,
you got 40 years left,
so you're not,
you're not done yet.
And so
the other thing I would say too is
it isn't exactly that.
I would say forgive yourself because you know,
that's just a cliche.
But I would say that once you've decided,
once you,
what you've done wrong and you've put into practice some,
some strategies to rectify that,
that don't,
you don't have to beat yourself any more than is necessary for you to learn,
which is a good rule of thumb with regards to treating yourself and also to
treating other people.
So
yeah.